who knew that dancing beside a big
purple dinosaur would eventually lead to
one of the most iconic careers of Our
Generation she's a pop singing sensation
film producer actress mental health
Advocate cooking show host entrepreneur
and one of the most followed people on
Instagram unless you are like hardcore
teen Haley you cannot help but love
Selena Gomez and as she recently hit
Apple TV with her biopic my mind and me
I feel like I can definitely relate to
the girl really well so today I'll be
channeling my inner bad liar and eating
like Selena Gomez for a day hey everyone
I'm Abby sharp welcome to Abby's kitchen
[Music]
foreign
like pop star Selena Gomez but I mean
not quite because my needs are unique so
I'll be using her alleged meals as a
template for teaching gentle nutrition
and inspiring what I make that works for
my body and me also a reminder that this
diet was compiled from some primary and
secondary sources so ultimately I cannot
speak to its legitimacy or accuracy and
another reminder that this is just what
I decided to eat on a random day and has
not ever meant to be copied or
recommended as how you should eat as
always please speak to a registered
dietitian about your unique needs and if
you are not already subscribed guys help
a YouTuber out hit that subscribe button
and follow me on Tick Tock and Instagram
at Abby's kitchen okay Abby I'm hungry
get at me okay so according to Selena's
trainer and nutritionist Amy rosoff
Davis Selena forgoes coffee in the
morning for some green tea instead I'm
not sure I love that idea but Abby are
there any legitimate reasons for this
swap okay first things first Abby like
we always say drink your caffeine how
you like it and let no one make you
question it but since you asked let's
lay down the facts so we know that
coffee provides about three times the
amount of caffeine compared to green tea
so for folks who are particularly
caffeine sensitive green tea may be a
better swap if they enjoy something warm
in the morning and still want to get
like a modest caffeine hit green tea
also contains the amino acid l-theanine
which metabolizes caffeine at a slower
rate so a lot of folks find that they
get a more stable so source of energy
throughout the day without the usual
coffee caffeine crash green tea is also
abundant in the antioxidants egcg which
is anti-inflammatory in nature and may
help protect against cancer but coffee
also has its own anti-cancer properties
thanks to antioxidants like CGA so yeah
six and one half a dozen in the other at
the end of the day it really comes down
to your own personal preference and
tolerance I also have a whole video
where I myth bust some common claims
about coffee which you can watch right
here yeah I feel like my day would be
totally ruined without my coffee but I'm
down to double fist it so let's make a
little green tea action and we can kind
of like you know hydrate all right a
little dip dip dip is this the technique
I do not know I'm not a tea drinker but
we'll take a little sip
foreign
it's not as good as this but again all
hydration is good at hydration so other
than the tea according to Vogue Selena
also makes a point to drink lots of
water
um and apparently it doesn't need to be
that fancy alkaline or lemon water so
yeah I can manage that folks
um and she also loves freshly squeezed
juice Abby what's the deal on juicing I
think you know what I'm gonna say here
Abby so let's just keep it short and
sweet Juiced fruits and veggies are
delicious refreshing hydrating and a
great way to get in some of those
micronutrients and antioxidants in one
solid big dose however it's worth noting
that juicers also strip fruits and
veggies of their natural fibers so
they're never going to be as satiating
as the whole fruit also Juice tends to
have higher concentrations of fodmaps
compared to the Whole Foods so if you
have a sensitive tummy or have IBS you
might want to ease in with the portion
sizes I'm admittedly not really a juice
person like I'm pretty sure I have a
juicer in the basement that I got like
seven years ago as a wedding present
that I still have not opened
[Laughter]
always does me dirty literally literally
doing me dirty here oh my God okay well
a little dribble whatever that's that's
my life as a mom I'm always covered in
something okay regardless I'm gonna go
with this one I found this at the
grocery store no need to Freshly squeeze
anything cold pressed fresh fresh and
delicious oranges watermelon pineapple
and lemon I feel like that's my style a
little sweet a little sour
mmm tastes like a sunrise I love that
with some tequila
she be bagging oh gotta get the water
gotta get the water we've got to have
the full morning lineup here all right
water tea juice my own addition coffee
enough with the liquids though let's
talk breakfast so according to Selena's
nutritionist breakfast is either a
breakfast burrito love that yogurt bowl
or avocado toast all solid options in my
opinion though I feel like I've had
enough avocado toasts and like smoothie
bowls or yogurt bowls with all these
celebrity diets to last me a lifetime so
we're making a burrito let's do it all
right scramble up some Eggies a little
salt and pepper
we'll do two eggs for a burrito
let's throw down
we're gonna just
scramble the egg I mean I don't know I
can't do an omelette I'm just that's
just not being my forte guys I'm
obsessed with corn and eggs I don't know
what it is the sweetness with the Savory
with the cheese
it just hits different so I got the corn
I'm gonna add in some bell peppers as
well and just like let it do its thing
oh we have cheese too but I'm gonna let
that move around for just a hot minute
before we get in there basically I like
a one to one ratio of eggs to cheese
I mean you do you
that'll do
hello
and basically I'm just gonna wait for
that cheese to melt and we're gonna
plate her up so as usual my avocado is
temperamental but I have this avocado
hummus and I was like hey why not let's
throw that bad boy in there's no rules
when it comes to burritos folks you put
in whatever you've got so I'm doing a
layer of that it's actually smells
really good and I love that I love the
idea of avocado hummus it's like the
best of all work worlds so that's going
down also I forgot to put the beans into
my egg mixture but it doesn't matter
because I'm just going to put some down
now so that's how recipes roll again
there's no rules throw those bad boys in
here comes the egg cheese veggie mixture
and
[Music]
we're gonna try to put some salsa in but
I know this is going to be a real messy
Adventure just a little on top for some
flavor
then when you bite into a burrito you
just got a mouthful of salsa that's the
experience I'm going for
this
rolling situation
is not my forte but
we're gonna give it a valiant effort
okay squeeze them tight
yeah they would fire me first day at
Chipotle faux show
I mean it's gonna be consumed
immediately so it's okay if it doesn't
like look great just gonna slop that
onto my plate
tuck in the sides a little more I'm
keeping it real guys I'm keeping it real
this is what most of my meals look like
just like how fast can I get them on my
mouth without getting them all over my
shirt let's serve this with some berries
so we got a little more color going on
I've got a nice big tub some
strawberries raspberries
grapes
I'm weirded out by the fact that my
grape just touched my salsa
not sure what I'm gonna do about that
but I'm just gonna keep keep going we
can just press on all right little
Blackberry this is enough before Oh God
do I wash it
I'm just gonna try to
just gonna try to be
more laid back than I naturally am about
it all right I think this meal is going
to require a napkin
so let's do one of these
this can go on the napkin
and let's talk about what we got we've
got lots of protein in our eggs and our
beans we got healthy fats in the avocado
hummus situation and some cheese in
there we've got fiber in the wrap and
the berries which are giving me a little
anxiety because they are touching the
salsa but I'm Gonna Roll With It
wish me luck friends
this is gonna be messy
um
but it's so good oh she's spicy too
yep
all right coffee check breakfast check
let's get in some movement so according
to Selena's trainer some rules that
Selena lives by when it comes to Fitness
is to stretch often for Mobility drink
enough water for hydration and never let
your body get bored I usually get a
little freaked out when I hear the word
rules but those are definitely some
rules I can get behind and apparently
she's into like a wide range of
activities so like yoga cardio Pilates
and Hiking with her friends
um but I live in Canada and it is cold
outside right now so hiking is
definitely off the table but I
definitely can get a little gentle
movement and let's go downstairs do a
little Pilates walk on the treadmill and
move our bodies
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
will usually have some sort of salad or
like a Powerball for lunch
um one of her go-to salads is what she
calls the power salad which contains
turkey avocado beans or chickpeas and a
homemade dressing of red wine vinegar
olive oil Dijon and lemon love this for
us
um I'm gonna get chopping and while I do
Abby can you guess like a little rundown
on Selena's diet rules so there is no
question that Selena has had a hard go
when it comes to her health from being
diagnosed with lupus to getting a kidney
transplant to battling bipolar disorder
I mean for 30 years young that's a lot
and while the headlines of course have
focused on what Selena eats for her Rock
and body I also get the sense that a lot
of her choices are to maintain her sense
of well-being and health and according
to her nutritionist the only diet rules
that Selena lives by include no weighing
no dieting eating more Whole Foods and
nourishing the body and so Soul we love
that so this is a great example of
making choices from a place of self-care
rather than from deprivation and
self-control and this approach feels
really on brand for Selena Who basically
developed an entire Cosmetics line that
is dedicated to promoting
self-acceptance self-love and mental
well-being Selena has also been very
vocal about how much she loves food so
much so that she even developed an
entire cooking show dedicated to cooking
with professional chefs if you guys
haven't watched it it is so cute
definitely hit that up but like all
celebrities Selena is no stranger to
gross body shaming in the media but
she's also being a champion on social
media for keeping it real and calling it
out I also love what she had to say
about this red carpet look I fluctuate a
lot with my weight and I remember this
night specifically I didn't feel good
about my body so what was really amazing
was that I actually got a chance to work
on the dress that fit my body that was
one of the moments where I was like I
don't have to be that 19 year old body
shape anymore because I'm not this isn't
stark contrast with other celebrities
who have dramatically and purposefully
changed their bodies to fit into a dress
and it's a good reminder that bodies
change they change as we age they change
through different phases of our life
cycle they change because of
circumstance like disease and medication
use so for example Selena has been
cruelly body shamed for her puffy face
and weight gain which was a result of
her steroids use to treat her lupus like
how cruel are people and I just want to
clarify that it's not just wrong to
comment on people's weight gain when
it's the result of a disease as if to
say oh well it's not their fault it's
also wrong and in very bad taste to
comment on people's changing bodies
period Abby I'm getting a little heated
up over here let's get back to the food
okay so I basically took Selena's
contact and I'm using what I have on
hand so we've got some Iceberg which
come at me I don't care yes it's less
nutritious than you know spinach but
it's way more delicious and the way I
see it is that it is like a blank slate
it is the canvas and I'm adding so much
great nutrition with all of this
beautiful color that it really doesn't
matter that the base isn't that
nutritious so I've got some bell peppers
and some Tomatoes going down I had some
corn that I had cooked
I'm going to throw that in as well
color
I got some deli turkey a la Selena some
chickpeas and this is something I
actually really like to do is like if
I'm gonna put you know an animal protein
on my salad I like to compliment it with
some plant-based protein as well just to
kind of balance everything out get a
little bit of all of that nutrition I
found an avocado let's just hope this
one's good I feel like it is yes you
just know when you put that first slice
in if she's gonna be good oh
totally deceiving definitely definitely
you steered me wrong you did me dirty
let's see if we can get some I think we
have some
respectable sections Let's see we can
cut out these bits
yep I think we're okay I mean we gotta
use what we can and whenever I do have
like a gnarly looking avocado one thing
I like to do is I just throw it into a
smoothie because it's gonna get Blended
up anyways in there there we go
couple pieces add some healthy fats
got some feta here
always love a little
feta and I actually kind of like like to
throw a little bit of the brine on top
because it just like Seasons everything
nice I've got some pita for some carrots
of course
because yeah a girl cannot live on
lettuce alone
throw that in there
and for the pita since we had that
avocado hummus earlier add a little
dollop right here for some dipping nice
and I've got this Green Goddess dressing
which is like so good that actually just
has like lemon juice and mustard and
like lots of fresh herbs olive oil
smells amazing
all right let's talk about it we've got
protein in our turkey and our chickpeas
plus healthy fats in the avocado and the
avocado hummus and all that beautiful
Green Goddess dressing and of course
there's tons of fiber rich carbs in the
pita and all the veggies that I threw on
top it's not exactly Salinas salad but I
feel like it definitely passes the power
salad test
oh
bro do you need to do a compilation of
me taking terrible salad bites because
they all look like that
all right it is snack o'clock let's get
into it so according to Teen Vogue
Selena's favorites include Cheetos love
it chocolate pickles and veggies and
hummus and I feel like this is a really
good example of what an intuitive
eater's favorite snacks would look like
like they're not all clean snacks and
they're not all like forbidden junk
Foods there's a little bit of everything
in there because it's probably just what
feels good to her body I'm gonna like
throw all those things on a plate and
we'll make like the most random
Smorgasbord of a snack let's do it all
right hummus
down
the carrots can go close to the hummus
but we have to create like a little bit
of a moat because I don't want my
Cheetos touching my hummus and I
definitely don't want my chocolate in my
house
all right
sweet pickles I have dill pickles too
but I don't know I feel like I need to
balance out the sweet and the Savory
components in this meal and so I'm going
sweet like come out because I feel like
these have like a cult following and I
have yet to fully experience it so
this was my reason to buy these today
not that we ever need a reason to buy
Cheetos and I'm pretty sure the most
important characteristic of a Cheeto is
this what do they call this the cheetah
the Cheeto the chi the cheetam the
chinam cheetish it has a name please
leave me a comment below this this has a
legitimate like culinary name the
cheetah the cheat cheats cheats
something effect
[Music]
we're gonna figure it out together I
also have my little
variety pack my little tickle trunk so
we will say of chocolate
and I'm feeling like
Mr Big
I love Mr Big
Mr Pig is this the one with the wafer in
it it's too big
do I have oh I actually what I meant was
Wonder Bar that's actually what I meant
Wonder Bar is the one that I wanted so
avondara
and yeah look at the snack plate I don't
actually know where to start with this
but
I'm thinking we're gonna start with the
Flaming Hot Cheeto because I am a
flaming hot Cheeto virgin
and I'm ready to pop this cherry
I can see why these are like
so popular they're spicy I'm not sure
how this combo is going to go but let's
try it for a second
a little bite of Cheeto
I don't hate it I don't we're just gonna
go to Circle I'm gonna make you watch me
do it
that's a nice way to end cleanses the
palette and then we start again
it is so effing cold it's like minus 20
outside I'm sure my Americans are like
Duff is that but I am like chilled to
the Bone I can't even like take my coat
off right now just picked up the kids
from school and I I'm like craving miso
soup and thankfully our girl Selena is
also a big fan of sushi so I picked some
up for dinner on my way home and
thankfully my kids are also super into
Sushi night let's see what we got all
right let's go where we got I got a
little Sushi sampler here so I've got
lots of protein and healthy fats in our
fish some carbs in our rice and lots of
fiber in our veg and also some more
healthy fats in the avocado always gotta
get edamame for some Fiber and protein I
upgraded my little salad to their
avocado salad so I got some avocado in
there for some healthy fats and the
reason I ordered in the first place miso
soup
somehow she's still warm for me in my
frigid car but I'm gonna just like sip
on this for a few minutes until I dethaw
myself get myself undressed and sit down
with the kids for dinner
oh what's so good
all right let's finish this day off with
something sweet Selena girl give me
something good I'm excited about this
but I have a confession to make I like
chocolate but I don't love it I
definitely don't like it all on its own
if there's chocolate I have to have
something to balance it out just because
just the one note chocolate is too rich
for me so I'm gonna show you how I'm
gonna do some chocolate cake and turn it
into a hunger crushing combo let's do it
step one
buy a chocolate cake because you guys
know I'm not making it from scratch so I
got a nice little slice here
and like
if you love your chocolate
just have the chocolate cake there is no
reason you need to turn everything into
a balanced meal if that's how you like
it but I just know for me
I guess it's just because I'm getting
old I just feel better when I'm having a
little bit more protein and healthy fats
before bed especially if I'm going to be
having something with a little bit more
sugar in it not to mention I just like a
little color in there too so I got my
chocolate cake
I got a big scoop of some vanilla Greek
yogurt
got some strawberries here
any other kind of berries in my
little Bowl here
some almonds for some crunch
I know this technically is a forkable
dessert but I already dirtied this one
up and I'm not gonna dirty another one
so to recap we've got some protein in
our Greek yogurt we've got healthy fats
in our nuts and fiber in all those
berries plus the fun Factor we got our
chocolate
satisfying and satiating that's how I
like to do dessert
um
okay so this girl already won me over
with calm down but she's really got me
now that I know what a shining example
she is with her relationship with food
and her body she doesn't believe in the
usual offenders that are rampant in
Celebrity Wellness circles like weighing
or dieting or pseudoscience Wellness
Trends instead she approaches food and
movement from the same place that she
approaches most things in her life from
a place of self-love and self-care she
eats the foods that are emotionally and
physically satisfying to her she's not
married to like a rigid workout routine
that doesn't feel good and she honors
her love of food by learning from the
experts and getting her hands dirty if
this is not an example of intuitive
eating I don't know what it is so that's
all that I have for you guys today folks
if you like this video be sure to give
it the thumbs up leave me a comment
below on Whose diet you'd like to see me
try out next subscribe to the channel
and I'll see you next time on Abby's
kitchen bye
foreign
[Music]